hallo leute mit wärmen bayern 63 an wert
unserer easyjet winter school
teilgenommen hat und es war schon lange
ein wunsch von ihm einmal eine easy
german zu moderieren
das macht er heute stehen wo ganze
herbst komme aus indien und wie lange
lernte schon deutsch besteht seit sechs
jahren deutsch spricht mittlerweile sehr
gut dass wir gleich sehen und jetzt
wollen natürlich wissen was ist dein
zimmer heute also unser unsere heutige
heutige thema ist was ist ihr lieblings
erfüllen genau ein thema das so einfach
ist jeder redet über ketten aber wir
haben noch nie eine episode darüber
gemacht ich konnte das auch nicht
glauben dass verein hat sich heutiges
thema auszusitzen
dann geht man ins mikrofon und geht's
los geht's
mein lieblingsessen ist schnitzel mit
kartoffeln und durfte mein
lieblingsessen sind hamburger
pferdeschwemme auf mein lieblingsessen
ich gehe mal mit sushi
ja und warum zuschickt weil leichtes und
man da viel davon so viel essen kann das
nicht mehr geht und damit trotz nicht
schlecht spaghetti und waren sagen die
spaghetti war zwar gut und schnell
bereitet pizza
mein lieblingsessen
ich glaube fish zum beispiel dorade
inside mein liebling werden
ich esse ich kein ende
ja was 70 ist in berlin
ja und zwar wir hätten hier fast nie
deutsches essen weil wir alles des
desktops aller welt haben da drinnen
mexikaner daneben arabisch auch sehr
populär
sava dahinter ist indes von hier schon
wieder asiatisch werden eigentlich wer
auf asiatisches und ganz viel gibt es
hier in auch indus und vietnamesische
million wusstest du dass ja ich wusste
das schon habe ich mir nicht nur es
erhält für fischstäbchen mit spinat und
kartoffeln und kochen sie das selber zu
hause ja sehr aufregend kann ich gar
nicht so genau beantworten
lieblingsessen pizza auto beispiel was
kostet er kann ein sehr gutes
kichererbsen curry machen einfaches aber
gerne so bunte salate mit ganz viele
sachen die weg müssen und dort mph und
gehaut credo
bei ihm weil sie hier in berlin berlin
metzger hat einige gäste war das da
drüben bei konnopke ich komme eigentlich
aus münchen und da schweinshaxe ein
faktor da war vom richtigen brauhaus
seien ja trocken wieder als selber zu
hause gehen und gucken die das selber zu
hause ja also mittlerweile auch er mit
frischem fisch häufiger als mit
fischstäbchen her und wo kann man das in
berlin am besten kaufen oder essen also
das kaufe ich eigentlich einfach im
supermarkt ein frischen jungen spinat
und kartoffeln und an den fischen weist
dann werden wir eine lange tradition in
deutschland mit fremden küchen und zwar
kommt das daher da wir viele immigranten
haben und die ersten gruppen die in den
sechziger jahren als gastarbeiter kamen
wie kam vor allem aus portugal
griechenland italien auch und dann
irgendwann auch aus der türkei ja mit
für eine griechische restaurant und
deswegen ist es auch heute noch typisch
dass wir in jeder packt jeder kleinstadt
und manchmal auch in jedem dorf findet
man immer eine pizzeria findet man immer
einen dönerladen und oft auch einen
griechen manchmal auch ein portugiese
und wo kann man am besten hier in berlin
hamburger essen an fast jeder ecke
berlin voll von guten hamburger leben
generell schwieriger wenn berlin liebe
ist also eigentlich so das typische
currywurst liebe die döner hier die
tiefen gemüse döner ja kaum selber nicht
von hier aber hat hier gewohnt und will
hier zu besuch hier
woher kommen aus frankreich ich mag sehr
gerne getan
junis und rafah kartoffelauflauf dafür
dass mit kartoffelbrei trocken sie das
selber zu hause
ich mag sehr gerne partie in spanien
macht man quartier mit kartoffeln und
betrieben
da kann man noch fleisch reinhauen und
alles mögliche was esse ich sehr gerne
wann haben sie das letzte mal hamburger
weg.de minuten und kochen wieder als
erneut zu hause ein bisschen mühsam das
zu machen weil die pfanne zu groß ist
und weil man das wenden muss die ganze
zeit aber eben mit meinem großvater habe
ich die früher sehr oft machen kennt
seine chips an
ja ich glaube hätte bedeutet coole
personen ja so sehen die hipster
wichtrach alle sind ja ein bisschen
hilft er in berlin das von dieser
modernen leute die mit den rennrädern
rumfahren und die langen werke fahren
und dir in berlin kann man schon dort
beobachten es gibt ja auch nicht alles
verläuft immer so elektromusik als es
ganz hübsch eingerichtet und auch die
esskultur historisiert sich mal sagen
sollte dieser burger an dass er früher
ein ganz normaler bürger laden und dann
muss immer mehr als dann kommt immer
mehr dazu zumeist auf jeden fall immer
vegetarische burger und mittlerweile
muss als auch in jedem laden vegane
sachen geben
das ist typisch für berlin und wie der
ganze laden hat sich einfach vor einem
halben jahr oder suchen sie sich
renoviert haben einfache gewitter einen
einrichtungen gemacht verkaufen die
gleichenberger wie vorher aber jetzt
sieht es aus wie ein luchs balladen in
berlin und wir hier in berlin gibt es
hier so viel internationales essen was
man fast nicht mehr typisch teufels
findet was ist ein typisch deutsches
essen was sie jemand empfehlen würden
der von etwa in deutschland ist
kartoffelgerichte
jetzt mit kartoffelpüree was gibt
dennoch bedeutet essen was man retten
leute läufern
ihre gibt er alles mögliche
irgendwelchen schweinebraten und kann
also weg mit ehrlich gesagt nicht viel
ein also sehr wenig deutsch essen als
deutsche glaube ich denke mal auf dem
land eher nicht so da ist man schon eher
deutsch aber in einer großstadt wo so
viel angebot ist von asiatisch mit
italienisch französisch da ist man schon
eher international endlich haben wir in
berlin ein deutsches restaurant ist das
ja gar nicht zu toppen kann hier gibt's
nur fast ja nicht nur deutscher gerichte
kennt für diese gerichte eine
geschwungene weiße kerze seit langem
schon grad das sind circa die nudeln
also selbst gemachte nudeln mit kälbern
roulette hatte das glaube das ist sind
fleisch kann durch verschiedene fleisch
sein ist eine frikadelle seien quasi
einen haufen fleisch vermacht und
gebraten gemüse torte hier
geschnetzeltes das ist auch ganz typisch
hatte das schon mal gehört habe ich nie
gehört geschnetzeltes ist wenn man so
ein fleisch dazu nimmt man entweder
hähnchen oder feierte in kleine streifen
schneiden und dann dreht und dann kommen
damals noch pilze und zwiebel nation und
so eine schöne dunkle soße seine chance
jung soo sie zum beispiel ganz lecker
mag ich sehr gerne und zieht es
natürlich noch schnitzel und
schweinebraten und wo kann man am besten
hier in berlin spaghetti essen gern mit
unserer episodische heute danke danke
schön und der verhinderten was ist dein
lieblingsessen
mein lieblingsessen escort schicken dann
wenn die spezialität und auch die
italienische küche zum beispiel pizza
wer will er auch heute niemand genau
und was ist dein lieblingsessen mein
lieblingsessen ich habe eigentlich viele
lieblingsessen aber hier in berlin es
ist sehr gerne teil eines essen und
frühe oder eigentlich für das typisch
deutsche essen was ich am liebsten mag
war immer früher grün kohlen dass du
auch typisch stolz da hat man sich dass
es um kohl und darin hat man somit
würden ja und jetzt herzlich wissen was
ist euer lieblingsessen das läutet er
uns mal in die kommentare schreiben
vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal
deutlich essen probiert das wollen wir
natürlich wissen wie hat es geschmeckt
habt ihr es gemocht und was wahr ist
danke das ist so gesehen hat und wenn
ihr lust hatten auch übungen zu machen
zu dieser episode und das vokabular zu
trainieren
dann werdet unbedingt ein mitglied bei
patchen bei uns dort bekommt ihr jede
woche übungsleiter zu den episoden danke
frieren weil sie schon
ich hoffe nächste mal kommen nach indien
und probieren dort mal sein essen gerne